[Music]
scientists predicted what would happen
but it was too late
[Music]
[Music]
this is same Walden if anyone can hear
this broadcast I'm still on earth this
is dr. Walden transmitting on frequency
1943 the world we once called home
appears of turn against us the
fundamental principle of nature is
survival it is in our soul to seek life
no matter what I heard the radio
transmission where is everyone else
there is no one else did the same
everywhere yes was same everywhere bozo
I before I was gonna be a teacher but we
weren't ready for that you're going to
the final Exodus launched this work for
my dad leaving was just a last resort
I saw dozens of people starve to death
because of hope how I made the same
mistake twice when do we leave the final
shuttle offer these at 48 hours
a long way to travel we mess up and we
die we need to see the night in the
toxic zone it's not possible it's
possible but farther than I've ever gone
let's do this they moved the launch site
trust me
[Music]
[Music]